breaking news we just hit two all-time
highs that you need to know about
bitcoin addresses on the bitcoin network
they're super transparent we can see
exactly how much bitcoin is in every
single one of those addresses and the
first all-time high we hit was bitcoin
addresses with at least a balance of
0.01 bitcoin now this isn't a huge
amount of money it's about 400 or so at
today's price but ultimately what we are
watching is retail investors simply
continue to dollar cost average they
continue to accumulate bitcoin and
they're not selling now that we have
over 9.85 million bitcoin addresses on
the bitcoin network with at least .01
bitcoin in their balance that means an
all-time high but that also means that
all those plebs all those bitcoiners
around the world they continue to stack
sats regardless of what's happening in
the macro environment or regardless of
what's happening from a geopolitical
standpoint but that's not the only
all-time high that we've recently seen
we also just saw a brand new all-time
high in the number of bitcoin addresses
that have at least point one bitcoin as
well that's about four thousand dollars
and what we're seeing there is that now
more than three point four million
accounts have over four thousand dollars
in their balance in bitcoin that means
that whether you're just buying a couple
hundred dollars or a couple thousand
dollars bitcoiners continue to stack
sats
they do not care the bitcoin network
doesn't care either it continues to
produce block after block after block of
transactions and the bitcoiners continue
to dollar cost average and the hardest
sound is money the world's ever seen
there's lots of fun there's lots of
mainstream headlines and there's all
sorts of stupid critiques and attacks
but bitcoiners they're laser focused so
they got the laser eyes on twitter they
continue to say to themselves i simply
want to dollar cost average into brand
new critical savings technology and
that's what you see when we hit all-time
highs and the number of addresses on
chain with 0.01 bitcoin balances and at
least 0.1 bitcoin balances as well my
guess is these metrics are only going to
continue to go up as we get more and
more distribution of bitcoin across
millions and millions of people around
the world don't be surprised if we
eventually have tens of millions of
people holding hundreds of dollars worth
of bitcoin that's right around the
corner and i can't wait for it to get
here hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time